You're gonna have to figure out, understand, and
take positions on, either by going to a
posek or by discussing it with the rav.
So what are some of the things which
come up that you just have to know?
So let's start with preparing
for Yom Tov. Even early, the same experience,
once one starts learning the Halachos of the
Yom Tov. So when it comes to Tishrei,
I always start with Hilchos Sukkah because the
seder of the shailas, you first get Hilchos
Sukkah shailas. Right now, you already have the
baalabatim are already thinking, Baruch Hashem mi keamcha
Yisrael, so right now they're thinking about the
pergola, pergola, I don't know how you pronounce
it, so those are the shailas, and already
had, and if you want to have a
tree-free sukkah, so that's a shaila for Sukkos.
You gotta get your tree cut it down,
you can't wait till, wait till erev Yom
Tov, then they know it's erev Yom Tov,
they charge you much more. You have to
get them now. And then if you want
to have, two people are taking off their
roofs off their porches, so they want to
know what's left, have to make sekach. So
I always start with Hilchos Sukkah because that's
usually what comes first. The Hilchos of exactly
how the tekiass sound, that comes usually a
bit later, unless you have to train a
new baal tokeia. So but the issues that
I think, I think the issues that will
come your way on a Yom Tov that
you have to figure out are the issues
of how to deal with some of the
new stoves and the issue which comes up
now that Baruch Hashem more and more people
are in Eretz Yisrael and more and more
people spend Yom Tov in Eretz Yisrael. So
if you're a rav in a Yeshivish community,
you will not get the shaila of Yom
Tov Sheni. If you're a rav in a
Chasidish community, you also won't get the shaila
of Yom Tov Sheni. But for some reason,
if you're a rav in a modern type
community, then you'll get the question of keeping
Yom Tov Sheni. So Yom Tov Sheni in
Eretz Yisrael, person an American goes to Eretz
Yisrael. So the Mishnah Berurah has a davar
pashut ad meod that there is the Halacha
of the when we go to different places,
we keep the minhagim sheyatzu misham. So we
go to Eretz Yisrael, we have a, we're
Bnei Chutz L'aretz, so some will see it
as a detriment of Chutz L'aretz, others see
it as a gevaldige thing, you get two
days of kedusha. However you look at it,
but you come to Eretz Yisrael, you're a
Chutznik, you have two days, kach hadin. And
that is the position of all as far
as I know of all the Gedolei HaPoskim,
Rav Shlomo Zalman beshaato, Rav Elyashiv beshaato, even
further back, Rav Tzvi Pesach. Rav Shlomo Gold,
he wrote a biography, he wrote an autobiography,
he was a rav in Toronto and then
he went to Eretz Yisrael, so he wrote
an autobiography. I was very interested because I
know from when you're a kid you don't
you hear all sorts of different things about
the politics of the community, but you hear
it as a kid. So when I grew
up, I wanted to, I was very excited,
now I'm going to figure out what were
they talking about? What were some of the
things going on behind the scenes? But it
is he didn't write anything, he was such
a sanitized version, I learned nothing of the,
what I wanted to learn. But a lot
of other things. So he writes there that
when he was a, he was a talmid
in Ponevezh when it wasn't people didn't go
to Eretz Yisrael. But he was a talmid
in Torah Vodaath and Ner Yisrael and then
he went to Ponevezh, so he went to
Rav Tzvi Pesach erev Yom Tov and Rav
Tzvi Pesach, the way the conversation went, it
was, does he even ask? Of course you
have to keep two days Yom Tov. Rav
Moshe, Rav Ovadia Yosef, all the Gedolei HaPoskim,
don't have any shaila. And that's what I
said, that in the Yeshivish community and Chasidish
community, it's a davar pashut. We know it's
a davar pashut they have to keep two
days because the Beis Yosef in his Tshuvos
Avkas Rochel, so he says he doesn't understand
how the Chutznikim can have their own minyanim,
he thinks it's a violation of lo tisgodedu.
He didn't wonder why they're davening Yom Tov
on the second day. That was a davar
pashut to daven Yom Tov. But he was
surprised that what's the heter. We have now
teshuvos from the Teshuvos haGeonim that in Teshuvos
haGeonim so Jews would go from Bavel to
Eretz Yisrael and they kept two days in
Eretz Yisrael. So what was the, why is
it even a question? So there are three
sources, the three meshivim. First was the
Chacham Tzvi. Even before the Shaarei Teshuva writes
that Bnei Yeshiva that went to Eretz Yisrael
so they would keep one day Yom Tov.
Somebody told me that years ago a talmid
of Rav Amital asked him, so Rav Amital
said that the minhag in Yerushalayim is that
Bnei Yeshivas keep only one day. So the
Shaarei Teshuva quotes that and then the Shaarei
Teshuva quotes three or four other sefarim that
say otherwise. So the only ha'arah on that
is, it is that some question that there
was a bona fide opinion that Bnei Yeshiva
keep one day Yom Tov. But
l'aniyus da'ati those were Bnei Yeshiva that they
came and didn't have a return ticket in
their pocket. They came with a one-way ticket
and then when it was time to head
back if they're going to head back and
they didn't get married, if they didn't stay
in Eretz Yisrael so then. But nowadays Baruch
Hashem when we send the kid off to
yeshiva first of all he has at least
one return ticket. And then if his sister-in-law's
going to have a l'chaim because she gets
engaged he's also on the next plane back,
right? And then if his parents are going
to get honored at the local shul he's
also on the next plane back. So the,
I would say that that's a different metzius
than the time of when Rav Amital issued
his position and when he referred to the
minhag yeshiva Bnei Yeshiva. That's l'aniyus da'ati. But
the first of the great sefarim that
was moreh otherwise was the Chacham Tzvi. Chacham
Tzvi has a mechudash'dike approach. He says that
when do we say that a person is
noheig k'chumras sheyatza misham? So that's when if
they would end up staying they would be
allowed to keep that hanhaga, that practice. But
if when they would end up staying they
would not be allowed to keep that practice
so then even before they decide to stay
they cannot maintain their practice. So here he
says a Jew comes from Chutz La'aretz and
let's say he decides to stay, he's making
aliyah and then he would keep second day
Yom Tov, he over Bal Tosif. Right? An
Eretz Yisroeldiker who wants to keep a second
day, he wants to sit in the Sukkah
on Shmini Atzeres, it's a machlokes between Rav
Shlomo Zalman and Rav Elyashiv when an American
Jew is visiting Eretz Yisrael whether he's allowed
to sit in the Sukkah Shmini Atzeres. Rav
Elyashiv says of course he can sit in
the Sukkah, not Bal Tosif, he's an American,
he takes second day Yom Tov. Rav Shlomo
Zalman said he's an American Jew keep second
day Yom Tov, but he can't sit in
the Sukkah because sitting in the Sukkah is
Bal Tosif. So the Chacham Tzvi took the
approach that hoyil that if I would end
up staying so then I'm obligated to keep
the chumras hamakom sheyatza misham, that's correct, but
if I end up staying I couldn't keep
the chumra sheyatza misham, it'd be assur. So
therefore even b'sha'as that I'm not living there,
so the din of keeping the chumra sheyatza
misham doesn't apply. So that's the mechudash'dike mehalech
of the Chacham Tzvi. One can understand there's
a distinction, to understand why the distinction should
make a compelling difference l'maiseh I don't understand.
And I guess if a person follows all
the hanhagos of the Chacham Tzvi then he'd
be a candidate, he could follow this as
well. Although Rav Ovadia Yosef is very progeny
were not mekabel his position. Rav Yaakov Emden
was not mekabel the position. So you see
that it wasn't mekubal even the family wasn't
mekabel. So then lechoreh and what we don't
understand the Chacham Tzvi is that it's true
that if a person would sit in the
Sukkah on Shmini Atzeres he'd be over Bal
Tosef. But if he would relax and not
do Melacha is there Bal Tosef over there?
Why would there be Bal Tosef in thing
Melacha? So on the issur Melacha even I
can't say, I don't think the Chacham Tzvi
spells it out, but af hasvarah hard to
apply the Chacham Tzvi svara to the inyan
of Melacha. Then the Alter Rebbe, Alter Rebbe
has a mechudashdik approach that Yom Tov Sheini
is not doesn't attach itself to the person
but it attaches itself to the place. It's
a geographical bin. And if you're in Eretz
Yisroel so then it's one day Yom Tov.
If you're in Chutz La'aretz it's two days
Yom Tov. And if I understood the Alter
Rebbe correctly it has to do with the
hashpa'os and the oros of the Yom Tov.
That in Eretz Yisroel the oros of the
Yom Tov are so strong and so powerful
and compelling that once when they've spent one
day of a Yom Tov in Eretz Yisroel
so then all the hashpa'os that are supposed
to happen have happened. In Chutz La'aretz the
hashpa'os and the oros are somewhat different. And
you can't compare the oros of Pesach in
Eretz Yisroel the oros of Pesach Chutz La'aretz.
Of course you can't compare them, we know
that there's a Medrash that says Havu Atzivnu
Lacha Tziyunim that the mitzvos in Eretz Yisroel
are there the mitzvos in Chutz La'aretz the
Medrash, a peledike Medrash, Rashi, Ramban both quote
it, that in order that we get back
to Eretz Yisroel to keep all the mitzvos.
So exactly what it means we don't know
but it means something along the lines that
the mitzvos in Eretz Yisroel every mitzvah in
Eretz Yisroel that the hashpa'os and the oros
of the mitzvah are overwhelming and there and
the hashpao of the same mitzvah will be
different in Chutz La'aretz. Something along those lines.
So the Alter Rebbe said so you want
to get the hashpa'os of Pesach in Chutz
La'aretz you're going to need a two days.
So again I believe it's the Alter Rebbe
I assume that Chabad that all Chabad Shluchim
follow this and I assume and inna hachi
nami if a person follows the Alter Rebbe
in all hanhagos so then ya'aleh lo then
he has to follow this as well lechoreh.
Doesn't have to but probably that's appropriate. And
then the third was Rav Shmuel Salant who
raised it in a speculative fashion and Rav
Shmuel Salant approach Rav Shmuel Salant was the
sgan no he was the Rav HaRashi of
Yerushalayim at the turn of the previous century.
And one of the one of the gedolei
haolam at that point. The Aderes became went
to Yerushalayim to become the assistant to Rav
Shmuel Salant but I think Rav Shmuel Salant
outlived the Aderes. The senior rabbi outlived the
assistant rabbi. So the so Rav Shmuel Salant
is quoted as saying in the footnotes of
the Luach in Eretz Yisroel so the Luach
in Eretz Yisroel was put together primarily by
Rav Yechiel Michel Tukachinsky. The Luach in America
was put together primarily by Rav Henkin. And
then it was upgraded by Rav Margolis and
upgraded by Rav Henkin son together with Rav
Riff who was the son-in-law. Rav Henkin was
one of the ziknei gedolei haposkim besha'ato so
there was amongst the rabbanim in America so
some would bring their shailos to Rav Moshe
and some would bring their shailos to Rav
Henkin. And then Rav Moshe
lived after Rav Henkin. Our Rav Henkin established
a lot of protocols in America. All of
the sheimos how to how to write Harry
in a get how to write Edward in
a get how to write Mary Aleph. Rav
Henkin was one who came from Europe and
he sat down he was a rav in
Europe and a rav over here Lower East
Side and he established protocols for ksivas hagittin
and he created the transliteration. between Hebrew and
English and then it's been tweaked, but the
yesodos are still from Rav Henkin. And the
Mesadri Gittin all came to Rav Henkin for
questions about how to spell. He came to
Rav Moshe also, he chose Rav Moshe also.
And then Rav Henkin also was omed al
hamishmar many many things and he was a
one-man Torah observer to give hora'os to schools
and hora'os to communities. So the Luach was
primarily Rav Henkin's project and Rav Henkin was...
his parnassah came from Ezras Torah. He ran
Ezras Torah. That was the... he ran the
funding for the Talmidei Chachamim survivors who didn't
have means to support themselves. And Rav Henkin
when he... he was answering shailos all the
time but he held that he was being
supported by... he had a job to be
the maskir for Ezras Torah. So whenever he
would answer a phone call, he would he
would make a note of it so he
could make up the time to Ezras Torah.
And they found a notebook in his desk
where he had all the times he had
to make up Ezras Torah because his poskening
shailos for America wasn't an Ezras Torah job.
So he writes, so that's the American Luach.
So the Luach in Eretz Yisrael was Rav
Michal Tucazinsky. Rav Rav Michal Tucazinsky was one
of the Gedolei Yerushalayim and he was also
a phenomenal person. He was that knowledgeable about
astronomy that he became a member of the
Royal Astronomers of London. And so he had
a phenomenal set yedi'os. And Rav Michal Tucazinsky
is, he wrote the guide for Avelos, Gesher
HaChayim. Gesher HaChayim was like the, was the
first as far as I know the first
sefer that brought together halachos of Avelos in
a how-to and a manual form. All the
seforim we have nowadays on Avelos, they all
start with the Gesher HaChayim. And then now
some would disagree but every sefer the Gesher
HaChayim was the code, was the gold, what's
it called, the gold bar of Hilchos Avelos,
was that the gold standard of Hilchos Avelos
till many other seforim came out. But the...
that's the Gesher HaChayim that's known to most
people. And then he wrote the Luach and
then he has and then he wrote a
sefer called Sefer Ir HaKodesh. I think it
was primarily put together by his son Rav
Nissan from his notes I think. And that's
hilchos hamitzvos hatluyos ba'aretz and hilchos Yerushalayim and
hilchos Beis Hamikdash. So there he also wrote
the he'aros to his Luach. So there he
has it, Rav Shmuel Salant wrote that he
thinks that when a chutznik coming to Eretz
Yisrael should be careful not to say, not
to davven shel chol but should davven shel
Eretz Yisrael. And to be careful not to
make the brachos that belong to Yom Tov
Sheni. Should do, he has to do melachos
and has to do the mitzvos but he
should be careful not to make the brachos
which introduced a certain safeik in the Yom
Tov Sheni in Eretz Yisrael. So he has
a detailed approach of how a chutznik davvens
and how he says brachos. And he writes
at the end that if the other Gedolei
Hador would mekabbel this hora'ah then people should
keep it. And the assumption is but they
weren't mekabbel so then they shouldn't follow. Exactly
where was Rav Shmuel Salant coming from? So
here's the mahalach of Rav Shmuel Salant which
Rav Chaim also apparently taught,
he heard this from the Rav And that
is that when the Gemara says in Beitzah,
shilchu misam, they sent from Bavel to Eretz
Yisrael nowadays that we know that we are
baki, we are baki now in
the establishing the calendar that we no longer
have to worry about the shluchim coming, bekiei
b'kavia d'yarcha... could we go down to one
day? So shilchu misam, hizaharu beminhag avoseichem beyadeichem,
keep the old minhag, shema yachzeir hakilkul. So
the way they wrote... We would expect shema
yachzor kilkul. We would expect keep two days
Yom Tov. The lashon of hizaharu beminhag avoseichem
beyadeichem, keep the old minhag, that would raise
the question of what was the old minhag
when a chutznik came to Eretz Yisroel. Right,
a person from Bavel came to Eretz Yisroel
at the time of when they would send
out shluchim. So if he stayed and his
family in Bavel was keeping two days because
the shluchim didn't get there, but he's in
Eretz Yisroel, so the shluchim he knows what
the shluchim are saying. So Rav Chaim had
understood that when a chutznik came to Eretz
Yisroel at the time of Kiddush haChodesh before
it became a takana minhag, when it was
a response to not knowing what the shluchim
were going to tell you, but if you're
in Eretz Yisroel, you know, so you only
kept the one day. So Rav Chaim said
the lashon of hizaharu beminhag avoseichem beyadeichem raises
the question of whether a person from chutz
la’aretz had come to Eretz Yisroel he should
keep that old minhag. The old minhag was
when he came to Eretz Yisroel he only
kept one day. So when the Rav. presented
Rav Chaim's he'ara it was a safek. It
was a chumra. It wasn't Rav Chaim was
not saying a person should only keep one
day. Rav Chaim was saying heyos that the
lashon is an interesting lashon, heyos that I
have this safek. So then I don't know
if Rav Chaim said this or the Rav
said it because of Rav Chaim's he'ara, but
basically it came out to something along the
lines of Rav Moshe Soloveitchik. But the Rav
said that maybe one should put on tefillin
on the last day of Simchas Torah and
the last day of Yom Tov and the
last day of Pesach. Maybe if one puts
on tefillin during Chol haMoed one should put
on tefillin without a bracha on the second
day Yom Tov. And that I know he
was moreh hora'ah sometimes that if a person
went to Eretz Yisroel for Yom Tov, if
they asked the Rav he would say to
put on tefillin on the last day of
Yom Tov privately obviously without a bracha. The
more intricate hora'os like Rav Moshe Soloveitchik I
don't know. I remember the Rav discussing it
in shiur. But lema'aseh the Rav Moshe Soloveitchik's
hora'os and the chashash for Rav Chaim's safek
had not become well practiced. And when I
was younger and more courageous so people asked
me and if I thought a person was
holding so I would suggest this approach until
somebody came back from Eretz Yisroel who was
a serious serious Jew and said that Rebbi
it's you called it a day and a
half, it's not, it's twenty-two and a half
days. He said it was very very hard.
I mean finding somebody who was going to
make the bracha of borei pri hagafen for
the second time during the Seder and finding
somebody who's going to make a bracha of
achilas matzah and then HaMotzi. So when this
serious Jew said it was so difficult I
said okay, why should I be a yotze
min haklal? All the gedolei olam said it's
two days, bring the two days with the
brachos of two days with the davening of
two days. Rav Moshe Soloveitchik though wasn't accepted.
I don't know how much the Rav said
it lema'aseh. So, but there's because of the
misunderstanding what the Rav was saying so that
generated an approach in some of our circles
that a person when they go to Eretz,
then American living in Eretz Yisroel, American going
to Eretz Yisroel should keep only one day.
So that's a misunderstanding. The Rav did not
say that, that was not what I was
in shiur. The Rav was pointing out that
Rav Chaim, was machmir, was machmir that on
the second day Yom Tov when a Jew
from America comes to Eretz Yisroel he should
be concerned about the mitzvah d’Oraita of tefillin,
he should be concerned about the issur d’Oraita
of being mazkir shem shamayim levatala. It was
all mitoch chumra and pachad not mitoch being
mekel on anything. That approach though it seems
to me has become misunderstood and and and
and has bred many many people who come
to Eretz Yisroel and they live in America.
There are hora'os lekula, for example Rav Shlomo
Zalman said of a person, I was told
that he said of a person. So Shlomo
Zalman's mahalach as explained to me is that
he's an Eretz Yisrael guy if you're there
for Yom Tov. He has two homes. He's
a ben Chutz La'aretz and he's a ben
Eretz Yisrael for Yom Tov. So that's a
big chiddush to say such a thing. That
there is such a thing. It's not a
deah peshutah. But Shlomo Zalman is ashlei ravrevei.
When I asked Rav Schachter what is the
tipping point, so he said a rov, a
person in Eretz Yisrael for more than six
months. So then they're an Eretz Yisrael-diker. Less
than six months, they're a Chutznik. Right. And
for tax reasons people know exactly how many
days they're Eretz Yisrael or Chutz La'aretz, so
they keep a close cheshbon. So but again,
Shlomo Zalman is ashlei ravrevei. A person exactly
what he meant I don't know. Does he
mean every Yom Tov? Does he mean davka
the Regalim? Does he mean that the first
Yom Tov of a planned stay? I'm not
exactly sure of the details of Shlomo Zalman's
pshat. But that's a mahalach. Sometimes you'll have
people go to Gedolei Yisrael and they'll say
and the Gadol will have said what's the
plan? I'll say I plan to live here.
They'll say well if you find a if
you start dating, say I'll be dating over
here. And if you end up dating a
girl who wants to stay, will you stay?
Yeah. And if you end up, yeah, stay.
And if you end up getting a job
here, you'll say I'll stay. And if you
end up finding a shver who will support
you, sure stay. So some Gedolei Yisrael apparently
have said if that's the case and you're
dating, so maybe you'll end up staying and
that was enough to stay. I'm not sure,
I'm not sure. But those are all judgment
calls. Me’ikar hadavar, so le’aniyut da’ati what's happened
is that in our community there are many,
many more people who are spend Yom Tov
in Eretz Yisrael and they're spending Yom Tov
there because they have children there, they have
parents there, grandchildren there. So it becomes very,
very difficult. Going to Eretz Yisrael to spend
time with your children and they're going on
a tiyul and you can't join the tiyul
with your children and grandchildren and you may
have to take a car and they can't
jump with you at some point. So it
is and some people find it very, very
difficult, tircha. Some people find it as an
almost a political statement which is not in
our circles. But it does become difficult. And
that's why it's an important nekudah. In other
words, when something becomes challenging and inconvenient, it
is a reason to make sure that you've
got the halacha right. A person's inconvenience, a
person's tircha is a reason to go back
to the sefarim, learn through the sugya and
make sure. It's not a reason to take
a position though. Very sometimes tircha is a
reason. But because a person finds a particular
din inconvenient and difficult, that's not a reason
to say that we're going to follow Rabbanim
who say certain things or it's not a
reason to machria. It's a reason to go
through the sugya 100 percent. And the person
goes through the sugya and finds a chacham
to be compelling, nu, okay. Still, tzarich iyun
because you're going against a binyan of the
posek. Whatever it is, that's the sugya, that's
the parsha and these questions come up and
they come up with a very strong feeling
sometimes because there are many Jews in our
circles who have received hora’os that allow them
to only keep one day or they have
friends, whatever it is. So you have to
know the sugya. Yeah, go ahead. I'd also
heard of Rav Asher Weiss pasken like Rav
Shlomo Zalman publicly regarding Yom Tov. Bedi’avad? L’chatchilah.
In Eretz Yisrael for the Yom Tov? So
he can be mitztaref. Go ahead. And also
Rav Schachter says that there's a problem of
lo titgodedu if you're going to go with
a group, you're going to be in a
family where everyone's keeping one day, you're going
to keep two days. Sometimes it's also just
like very challenging. You're a yeshiva guy in
a Chol HaMoed-diker shvitz, you may not be
able to find anything to do. So what
does Rebbe think about that? Challenging is challenging,
okay. Challenging means that it's a... it's a...
challenge for one day. What about the Lo
Tisgodidu thing? The Lo Tisgodidu thing, Rav Schechter
said it in very, very limited situations. So,
I again, Rav Schechter just looks at the
situation and says... have to speak for him.
But but Rav Schechter has said it in
very limited situations. Tzaricha Iyun Gadol exactly why
mnyat melacha would be Lo Tisgodidu. I to
not to take a Lulav and Esrog they
wouldn't come up anyways because Hoshanah Rabbah. Not
to sit in the Sukkah I understand. Not
to join if you're in a program and
they're all davening chol so to have a
to daven in a visible way that it's
Yom Tov, I understand that situation. I don't
understand zu keneged mnyat melacha. But whatever it
is, it's in the Shu\"t Rav Schechter said
it, but very, very precise situations. I once
had a talmid whose family made Aliyah and
he was here, and he gets here. So
he went so he wanted to know about
one day, two days Yom Tov. And and
that's what you're describing that it's a that
it's a difficult thing. No question here. So
he asked me in the Beis Medrash, I
said Rav Schechter is five tables away, and
he's the ba'al Lo Tisgodidu shita. So so
he went to Rav Schechter, he said, but
you're in Beis Shemesh and Beis Shemesh there
are going to be a lot of Jews
who are going to keep second day Yom
Tov. So my point is that it's a
very tightly nuanced position. So one has to
ask him exactly does your situation fit his
his mahalach. I also once asked him about
this, and he also told me it's only
if it's within the same family, the same
nuclear family. It's not as if you're your
uncle and your aunt and your cousins that
are all keeping one and you're the one
who should be keeping two. It's only if
a son and his parents are there, the
wife and her spouse or the daughter, you
know, it's only within a nuclear family, not
in general people. In other words, if I'm
visiting my uncle, it wouldn't apply. Correct. Different
family, one does this, one does that, that's
not... But it sounds like also, but it's
also in the context where like like you're
in a lone shut situation where you're not
going to find... Yeah, so again, Baruch Hashem
if we can raise these questions Rav Schechter.
But then what you're saying is correct that
that is accurate, obviously, that that's another mahalach
that's sometimes available. Yeah. Good, so that sugya
of Yom Tov Sheini when an Eretz Yisroeldiker
comes to America, so then our our mahalach
in America is much more I always hope
that they ask the sha'alos in Eretz Yisrael
because Eretz Yisroeldiker is there much more easygoing
on an Eretz Yisroeldiker who comes to America.
Reb Moshe held that when you're part of
a community over here, so one has to
keep Yom Tov Sheini because of maris ayin.
And Reb Moshe paskened afilu b'chadrei chadarim. So
that seems to be the mahalach of American
poskim. Ela im kein an Eretz Yisroeldiker will
take get out of the Jewish community b'heter
and find themselves into a place where there
aren't any way beyond the techum of a
Jewish community. So then I think Reb Moshe
would say for them they can they can
function as an Eretz Yisroeldiker and and do
melachos. The Eretz Yisroeldiker poskim are much more
easygoing. I'm not sure I'm not sure if
it's because they don't know the metzius over
here or they hold in principle that there's
no problem of maris ayin for Eretz Yisroeldiker
in America. And the emes is it could
be that we should be mekil to allow
melacha if there are many, many more Israelis
around. You're in a community where there are
a lot of Israeli visitors, maybe. Okay, tzaricha
iyun. Good. So then the next question, let's
discuss the question of showering on Yom Tov.
Showering on Yom Tov is also something that
has shifted. Go ahead. A guy in Eretz
Yisrael who is safek or a guy from
Eretz Yisrael visiting America, but should he put
on tefillin when he's if he's if he
has to stay home, should he go to
shul, should he...? An Eretz Yisroeldiker who comes
to America so they should put on tefillin
privately at home and they and they can
chap a lot of davening but they can
chap tefillah b'tzibbur still and they can chap
krias haTorah. Or or parts of the davening
should they do b'tzibbur? In the ideal world,
so they would, the ideal world they would
come, come a little bit late so they'd
have a short Tefilla B'tzibur, chapp the Krias
Shma and then, and then from then on
they can daven with the Tzibur. They probably,
one of the pshatim is that they should
chapp a Hashkama minyan or something, but, but
al pi ideally, why not? They can, they
can daven with the Tzibur. Is it, is
it considered Tefilla B'tzibur if it's a different
Shemonah Esrei? Yeah, I think, I think it
would be. I think it is Tefilla B'tzibur.
You're not, you're not doing the same Shemonah
Esrei. You're together. That comes under the general
question of what's their shaila. The shaila is
that they would much rather head into some
other community and then they take an Uber
from there. So that's the chilluk of how
strong they have to what they have to
give up to do Tefilla B'tzibur. And then
what we're really saying is that maybe to
those poskim who say that it's not Tefilla
B'tzibur, because there's more reason to have less
adifus for Tefilla B'tzibur. But if they can,
then they can marviach, yeah. Rebbe would generally
give the psak from Rav Moshe? They have
to keep fully Yom Tov or go with...?
I mean they wouldn't be saying the brachos
and they wouldn't be saying... so like a
half day. They wouldn't, they would do melachos.
They would do melachos, yeah. Question the posek
would say, can they be a Shabbos goy
for their American cousins? So Rav Moshe would
say no, because that's mishum maris ayin. But
to be honest, it's most correctly ask Eretz
Yisrael, the rabbonim of Eretz Yisrael. They should
ask the rabbonim there. And my experience has
been that most of the rabbonim of Eretz
Yisrael will tell them that they, they don't
have to keep the Yom Tov Sheni. And
again, that's the issue of maris ayin. And
again it could be that, I don't know,
I don't know if the difference of, I
never looked into it, of the difference of
metzius of whether it's al pi din nowadays,
I don't know. Good. So now when it
comes, yeah. When there are poskim in Eretz
Yisrael even if they were a person who's
a ben Chutz La'aretz keeping one day in
Eretz Yisrael flying back, they would even be
meikel for him, or just Bnei Eretz Yisrael
coming back? Bnei Eretz Yisrael, Bnei Eretz Yisrael,
yeah. When a ben Chutz La'aretz kept one
day then they would agree with Rav Moshe's
tzad that it's the maris ayin issue. No,
a ben Chutz La'aretz goes to Eretz Yisrael
for Pesach and on the last day he
only keeps seven days as Bnei Eretz Yisrael
and flies back and then that morning he's
in the airport so the poskim in Eretz
Yisrael would say he can go home? I
don't think so. I think they, I think
there was a Kol Korei recently about that
nekuda that even should not be landing in
Chutz La'aretz while it's still Yom Tov. Right,
so that's one issue. Then the second, then
you're saying that a person let's say he's
in Eretz Yisrael for every Yom Tov. So
he's following Rav Shlomo Zalman, Rav Chaim Rav
Asher, and he's keeping one day Yom Tov.
So then, then I think that we would
tell him he should not be getting on
a plane that would bring him to Chutz
La'aretz on Yom Tov. Okay, but you're saying
but something happened, he didn't read the Kol
Korei, so he went to the airport, now
he lands in America so I think then
we would not say. So I'm not sure.
In other words how far do we take
that he's a ben Eretz Yisrael for Yom
Tov? I don't know, I don't know. I
mean, what you're asking is, you're asking a
question that I can't answer. You're asking if
somebody paskens for him that he keep one
day in Eretz Yisrael and he ends up
in Chutz La'aretz on Yom Tov, so that's
hard to answer because I have a bias
that he should have, that it's Yom Tov
for him. So I can't answer that question.
The question that you're asking about if he's
a ben Eretz Yisrael for Yom Tov, does
Rav Shlomo Zalman or Rav Asher say that
changes? So again, we should follow, should ask
Rav Asher what he would say, Baruch Hashem,
we'll find out. On Friday we'll take the
idea that he's in Ben Eretz Yisroel, does
that switch? There are seforim that discuss, that
discuss if he's a Ben Eretz Yisroel, but
if he every Yom Tov is in Eretz
Yisroel, let's say. And now this Yom Tov
he happens to be here, I think the
poskim, the Chazon Ish would say that then
he has to keep two days. I don't
understand it well enough to explain the cheshbon.
But yours is a little more nuanced. Okay,
to figure out the question. For some reason,
Kol Koreis that I don't know which rabbanim,
I don't know who put it out, but
they strongly, the Kol Koreis strongly discourage, the
Kol Koreis usually prohibit. So they're prohibiting Jews
from Eretz Yisroel from getting on the plane
such that they will land in America once
Yom Tov has begun, or land in Europe
also Yom Tov. Anyways, so let's go on
to a more cheerful, but a topic where
I think it'll be easier to be meikel,
that of showering on Yom Tov. So what's
the issue of showering? Showering is that the
person draws water from their hot water boiler,
so new hot, new water, cold water comes
in. So when you draw your hot water
off, so that there's no issur d'oraisa there
per se, but when you bring new water
into your hot water boiler, so then that
is an issur of bishul. And if you
bring a lot of cold water in, then
you might light up the fire again. And
the question is, is that muttar on Yom
Tov because I'm boiling up the water, but
the water for my boiler I don't use
for cooking. So I'm boiling up the water
either for no reason or for another shower.
Mishna in Beitzah says that ponei yadav veraglav,
that one can use hot water according to
Beis Hillel for ponei yadav veraglav, but a
person cannot use hot water for a shower
because that's more than ponei yadav veraglav. So
the question is, is there any flexibility on
that din from the mishna? So l'chora we
have to analyze it. L'chora the issue of
havuarah is and the issue of bishul. Right?
Havuarah and bishul. If you end up putting
the fire on or you end up cooking
the water. So the halacha is that one's
allowed to do havuarah and bishul l'tzorech ochel
nefesh. And the halacha is that if there's
tzorchei haguf which are which have the same
din as ochel nefesh, similar to shaveh l'chol
nefesh, so l'chora they should have the same
din as ochel nefesh. And why was Beis
Hillel meikel, why did Beis Hillel say that
ponei yadav veraglav is muttar? Because that's shaveh
l'chol nefesh. Shaveh l'chol nefesh is a hano'ah
which is like achilah. So you have a
hano'ah, and if you have a hano'ah and
it's not shaveh l'chol nefesh like Tosfos says,
so one cannot do a melacha for that
kind of hano'ah. But if a person has
a hano'ah which is like, which is shaveh
l'chol nefesh, so maybe that should have the
same din as ponei yadav veraglav. So the
question is whether bizmaneinu anu that a full
body shower is that in the same category
as ponei yadav veraglav bizman hamishna? So l'aniyus
da'ati, I would say that if it's a
situation where you have a Shabbos and two
days Yom Tov, and sakh ha-kol a person
will not shower for three days, so I
could see that somebody could argue that showering
in that situation is on the same category
as achilah. So why would I say that?
Because there's a Ksav Sofer that says that
to avoid tza'ar is shaveh l'chol nefesh. It's
hard for us to evaluate going against a
mishna p'rushah. So how can we go up
against a mishna p'rushah that says that it's
only ponei yadav veraglav? So the Ksav Sofer
says that that what eats has a certain
level of hano'ah and avoiding Tzar is Hana'ah
in similar category. So when a person comes
to showering, so L'chora a person only gets
to shower once every 24 hours, so L'chora
that's still within a pretty normal range of
activity. If it happens to be 48 hours,
so again after Yom Tov is going to
end up, it has like an extra day
of Tzar, so I'm not sure, I'm not
sure. But when it comes to three days,
so I think that there are many, many
Americans who will feel very, they'll feel B'tzar
that they haven't showered in three days. So
that's what I would look at. I would
look at the Matzav if there's a three
day situation, like three days of Kedusha and
one of those days is Yom Tov Sheni.
Apuki if Shabbos is Yom Tov Sheni. But
one of the three days Yom Tov Sheni,
L'aniyut Da'ati there'd be room to be Moreh
that one can take a shower on the
Yom Tov Sheni. What's the, how can we
explain such a Hora'ah? So first of all
we'd be following the Ktav Sofer that says
that a Melacha which is being done to
avoid Tzar and we'd be saying that the
person feels that three days without a shower
give them Tzar. And again I think that
there are a lot of people that would
take that position personally. I'm not saying it's
such a Davar Pashut that I would advocate
it, but when a person asks, I say
look if you're B'tzar, so then on the
second day of Yom Tov when the Melachos
are D'rabbanan anyways, so what are we looking
at? I'm pulling off hot water. So then
I'm going to do a Psik Reisha. A
Psik Reisha to bring in more water that'll
cook. I'm going to do a Psik Reisha
that will bring more water, that might put
on the fire to cook this water. What's
this water going to be used for? Also
for a shower. So I'm doing a Melacha,
I'm doing Havarah and Bishul L'tzorech a Davar
Hashaveh Lechol Nefesh because otherwise it leads to
Tzar. So L'chora that there'd be room to
be Mekil on Yom Tov Sheni. So Az
it's hard to go against a Mishna Meforeshet
but Yom Tov Sheni, so it's going to
be a Psik Reisha on a D'rabbanan. There's
another Mahalach Be'ma Nafshach. If I end up
using that water for another shower, okay, so
then I'm using it for Davar Shaveh Lechol
Nefesh. If I don't end up using the
water for anything, so then it's a Psik
Reisha D'lo yichpad lei. So a Psik Reisha
on a Din D'rabbanan D'lo yichpad lei which
is L'tzorech Mitzva, L'tzorech Simchas Yom Tov, so
that's many many Poskim I think that it
would be possible to be Mekil on that.
Most hot water heaters I believe, I'd have
to check out, I believe that most hot
water heaters still have a pilot light. So
therefore there's no issue of Molid Esh. I
believe that's correct. So if it doesn't have
a pilot but has an electrically ignited, which
might be the way things are going, so
then that would be Issur D'rabbanan of Molid.
So that's Tzaricha Iyuna, but again it'd be
a Psik Reisha on an Issur D'rabbanan of
being Molid. It wouldn't be Molid or to
do Bishul even though it's an Issur D'rabbanan.
But this would be a Psik Reisha, it
might even be a Safek Psik Reisha because
it could be that the temperature has gone
down and that the lights are on anyways.
That we wouldn't be Samech on as we'll
discuss often. But it would be a Psik
Reisha D'rabbanan and again Be'ma Nafshach either you're
going to use the water and it's a
Davar Shaveh Lechol Nefesh or you're not going
to use water and then it's Psik Reisha
D'lo nicha lei on a Din D'rabbanan. However,
what has to still be figured out is
Gzeiras Habalanim. Hagemara in Shabbos says that there
was a time where people, one of the
ways in which people enjoyed Oneg Shabbos is
that they would have a Shvitz on Shabbos.
So there were Balanim, there were people who
ran Shvitzim and they would advertise Shomer Shabbos
Shvitz, right? And we boiled up all the
water Lifnei Shabbos, we have a system where
we keep all the hot water. in pipes
to create steam, so it's gevaldig, you get
all the hanoyis of a shvitz on Shabbos
and you had a gevaldig hashgocha that everything
was taken care of before Shabbos. Only problem
was that some of the balanim would refill
their hot water systems on Shabbos. They would
advertise that it was a Shomer Shabbos shvitz,
but it wasn't a Shomer Shabbos shvitz. So
Chazal made a takana was two iterations. Chazal
made one takana, then the balanim were saying
that it was—but weren't telling the truth about
the second takana, until Chazal said that there's
a gzera mimercatza'os on Shabbos. Gzeras habalanim. Because
of the balanim, that's why they gave it
the title and didn't call it gzeras mercatza'os.
I think they wanted to tell people that
they made this gzera because of the dishonest
balanim. So that's why one cannot—it's another issur.
Now let's say a person would leave their
shower on from erev Shabbos. So one still
could not take a shower Friday night. Why
not? If the shower, the hot water's coming
on its own? Because there's an issur taking
a merchatz, apparently included in the issur of
being in a shvitz is taking, is sitting
in a situation where hot water is coming
down. So that'd be an issur derabbanan. So
how could I take a hot shower on
Yom Tov? What about gzeras balanim? So le'aniyus
da'ati, I would argue the following. There is
a machlokes Rishonim whether gzeras balanim applies to
Yom Tov or only Shabbos. And there is
a machlokes Achronim whether the mercatza'os, it was
only, is only a bath, so even hot
water coming down from the top. And there
is a machlokes Achronim whether gzeras balanim applies
to mayim poshrim, to the water that's not
hot. So even though we pasken against, we
pasken le'esor all of these three situations, we
pasken on Yom Tov we also do not
go into the shvitz, and we pasken that
even if it comes from the top it's
a bath, and we pasken even if it's
mayim poshrim. However, le'aniyus da'ati, one could argue
that on a Yom Tov sheini, so it's
a din derabbanan to begin with, and we
have these various sfeikos in the Achronim as
to whether it applies. So I would say
one could take a mayim poshrim, one can't
take a full hot shower, but could take
a warmer shower on a Yom Tov sheini.
What's the hesber hadavar? From the perspective of
a de'oraisa, if a person says \"I'm comfortable\"—it's
a problem, \"I'm comfortable\". It's the guy's neheneh,
so probably wouldn't be meikil. But if a
guy says \"no, I'm betza'ar many people, certainly
younger people, they'll say they feel gross if
they don't have a shower in three days.
Okay. So if there's a Yom Tov sheini
there, so I would say a person who's
betza'ar. So therefore we can say that there's
a davar hashaveh lechol nefesh. And we can
say that either it's a davar hashaveh lechol
nefesh or it's a psik reisha on an
issur derabbanan dilo nicha lei. So then we
could, because Yom Tov sheini, and if we
say that in addition you take a lukewarm
shower—not lukewarm but not a very hot shower—so
we can say that there are several sfeikos
as to whether the gzeras habalanim apply. So
even though in and of itself we're machmir
on the gzeras habalanim, but here where it's
a gzeras habalanim on a davar derabbanan to
begin with, and we do have Achronim who
are meikil in many of these situations, I
would say that would be muttar on the
Yom Tov sheini to take a mayim poshrim,
not mayim chamim. At the same time, you
have to instruct people not to use bar
soap and not to use poufs and not
to lather up because of the various halachos
that are involved, gzeiros and mishum schita. Velichora,
that would be a mahalach that would make
people more comfortable. What about drying hair? You
would pat dry, pat dry should be okay.
If you tell a woman, a woman who
goes to mikvah on Friday night, so also
tell them to use more than one towel
so that no towel becomes sopping wet and
to pat themselves dry. But they're air drying
a little bit. Good. So then the next
issue that one has to understand is how
one deals with ovens and stoves on Yom
Tov. So l'chora, and because there's been significant
changes in the last 20 years with the
stove and the ranges becoming more electrically controlled
rather than just gas controlled. And the teshuvos
that are most popular are teshuvos that deal
with gas stoves, gas pilot light, but the
heights still has them. Right, so you have
a gas stove and there's a little light,
the ner tamid inside and it's going mamish
24/7. And when you turn on your stove,
so then the flame shoots from the ner
tamid to the where it ever has to
be. So that's gvaldik because there you have
a there you're not molid or, not creating
a new fire on Shabbos, on Yom Tov,
on Yom Tov. Shabbos obviously you can't do
it, but on Yom Tov where there ha'avara
l'tzorech ochel nefesh is mutar and bishul is
mutar, so it's gvaldik. Can you lower the
flame? So you can only lower the flame
if we would assume that lowering the flame
is kibui, and kibui can only be done
l'tzorech ochel nefesh. So if you have to
keep something warm, but you can put it
on a high fire so you have a
soup and you need to keep it warm
for the meal. If you put it, but
you only have one high fire there. If
you put the soup on high fire it's
going to end up boiling and boiling and
boil off and become very, very salty. So
you have to put it on a lower
flame. If you have it on some flame
so it'll be, you can't put on high
flame because that'll burn off and become too
salty. So then you can turn the fire
down so then to be able to put
the soup on that fire. You have a
chicken, and you want to keep the chicken
warm. But if you keep the chicken on
the flame that you have right now it'll
become burnt. So you're allowed to lower the
flame so that you won't end up doing
a kibui l'tzorech ochel nefesh. So that is,
so that's how we would handle old style
stoves on Yom Tov, lot of flexibility. However,
when you move to electric stoves, so then
you run into an issue that when you
switch heat in an electric stove, there are
different kinds of electric stoves. Sometimes, and it's
rare, it's very rare, that you would maintain
the same circuitry, but you would introduce, I
don't know exactly what it is, some kind
of resistance so that either you have more
or less electrons going through, and that would
raise or lower the fire. Most of the
time, what you have is an electric stove
and you move from 250 to 350, mostly
you're shutting down the 250 circuit and you're
opening up the 350 circuit. And if you
do that, so you're being mechabeh 250, and
that's not l'tzorech ochel nefesh. But more problematic
is you're being molid or, you're starting a
whole new fire for 360, for the 350.
Can't be molid or. That's one problem. Other
problem is if you have a gas stove,
so gas stoves nowadays, gas stoves don't have
pilot lights. Gas stoves nowadays have electric igniters.
So if you move the fire from 250
to 350, in the heights you just add
more fuel, more gas. But in an electric
stove you are starting a new flame that
will bring the fire up to the point
it'll get up to 350. So one of
the curiosities of Hilchos Yom Tov is that
even though you're allowed to... Even though you're
allowed to cook le-tzorech ochel nefesh, but you
can't be molid ur le-tzorech ochel nefesh, right?
And the issur d'rabbanan, min de'oraisa you can
strike a match, min de'oraisa you can do
any havara, havara le-tzorech. Chazal made a din
that you cannot start a new flame on
Shabbos ve-Yom Tov. That's why every Yom Tov
people have 24-hour, 48-hour, 72-hour candles. Sometimes they
double as Yahrtzeit lights, but they have a
function that they they have they're able you're
able to transfer fire from them to any
other situation where you need fire because you
don't have to be molid ur. What's the
issur of being molid ur? It's a machlokes
Rashi and Rambam. The Rambam says that being
molid ur is a melachas ochel nefesh she-efshar
la'asosah me-esmol. That since I could have a
pilot light going, since I could have a
72-hour candle going, so I'm able to have
do this kind of havara me-esmol. So a
melacha, a melachas ochel nefesh she-efshar la'asosah me-esmol,
certainly a melachas machshirei ochel nefesh she-efshar la'asosah
me-esmol is assur. So the Rambam writes starting
maintaining a fire that I can't do from
yesterday because my fuel gets used up, so
to add fuel that's a melacha I need
to be doing moment by moment on Yom
Tov, but to start a fire that I
could do erev Yom Tov. So the Rambam
says that nekudah, that that ma'aseh havara of
being molid ur, so that was efshar la'asosah
me-esmol so I can't do it on Yom
Tov. And Rashi has a mechudash'dik approach. Rashi
says that being molid ur, the idea of
being molid, Chazal said that since molid is
similar or is a is conceptually connected to
melachos Shabbos, so therefore Chazal made it assur.
A very mechudash'dik approach. In other words, what
Rashi is pointing out to us is that
we are very familiar that Chazal will say
that I can't put a plant in the
ground on Shabbos, seed in the ground, and
I can't put a plant in the ground
on Shabbos, and I can't water something on
Shabbos, but I but I can't even do
something which looks like I can't move a
plant into the into the light if it's
going to give it greater gidul. So it's
a specific ma'aseh which looks like a ma'aseh
de'oraisa, right? That we understand. Here Rashi said
that Chazal when it came to molid they
looked at melachos be-klal. They said melachos be-klal
are creative activities, so if I do something
which looks like it's creative that's an issur
of being molid. It's a different way than
we normally think of dinim de-rabbanan, that they
looked at the conceptualized the melacha of the
issur and said if I do something which
is conceptually similar to the issur that's also
de-rabbanan, being molid, creating a new that's why
we have a din on Shabbos ve-Yom Tov
one cannot create a new form. One cannot,
I mean it's a machlokes exactly, one cannot
take a liquid or a gas and make
it into a solid. I just had a
very interesting sheilah about making slush. Can you
have a slush maker on Shabbos? Put a
slush maker on a Shabbos clock. And then
add it, so my machshavah first was that
to make slush you're making ice, so most
of the poskim say that one shouldn't make
ice on Shabbos. So even though the slush
maker is going, but when I put the
water in I'm making new ice. So Rav
Shlomo Zalman points out that there are there
are poskim, I think it's Tzitz Eliezer who
is meikel on who holds making ice is
not molid. Rav Shlomo Zalman said that his
lashon is that one should be machmir, one
shouldn't make ice on Shabbos. But then when
I looked into the the science of slush,
so I thought this was very interesting that
a slush maker has two things going on.
On one hand it's making ice, the temperature
of the water is below freezing point, but
then they have two systems that stop the
slush from becoming a block of ice. One
is they have things moving around all the
time so that the it becomes balls of
ice, and the other is that they send
antifreeze through. through some pipes within the slush
maker, so again for the same reason it
shouldn't become a block of ice. So microscopically
when you look at slush, it's little balls
of ice sitting in water. So it never
becomes a solid block of ice. Macroscopically, I
don't know that's that's our experience, you know,
when you go into a 7-Eleven, so you
think you're walking out with a with a
cup of of little balls of ice. I
don't know if you see that you have
balls of ice that are sitting in liquid.
So tzarich iyun, that's why when this person
asked me what to do for his youth
group, so I thought that the Shlomo Zalman
says you shouldn't make ice and I thought
that even though microscopically you're you're making very
small balls of ice and keeping them so
they shouldn't become this solid, so maybe you
could say that I'm just making a a
thicker liquid. It's not mamash content of the
powder, but I'm not and do I look
do I say I'm creating little balls of
ice or are you creating a a slow
liquid because my ice is free-flowing? So I'm
not sure. I thought it would anyways be
ovdin dechol and if it makes noise it
could be avsha demilta. But then the Rabbi
told me that the family in in many
shuls, it's it's people are doing it for
the youth groups. He gave me certain communities,
not not local. So I said I don't
know. I said I didn't realize that the
psak is out there already, but I'll look
at it much more carefully. And if it's
being done already, so maybe it's not ovdin
dechol. But it has to take a stand
what to be ma'ale shulchan melachim, that's the
nekuda. Is it considered are you being molid?
First of all, there are many poskim who
who allow making ice. But let's say you
want to take the approach that you can't
make ice, so was this called making ice
because you you make little balls of ice
but you still making it in a in
a pourable fashion. Tzarich iyun have to be
ma'ale shulchan melachim. So what does it do
with us? Molid, right, so that's the issur
of molid. So so Rashi says the issur
of molid and the Rambam the issur of
molid, and therefore being molid or is assur
on Yom Tov even letzorech ochel nefesh. So
havara and bishul is muttar, but being molid
or is assur. kach hadin. So so if
you have the if you still live in
the Heights and you have and you haven't
upgraded your oven and you have a pilot
geburning because there's no molid or and you
can you can fire up and you're doing
bishul. If you have an electric oven, an
electric range, electric oven, so then you're in
trouble because you have to know how does
the circuitry work and it's very very I'm
I'm told it's most likely that you're changing
circuitry being mechabe and being molid or that
you can't do on Yom Tov. And if
you have a modern-day gas stove, probably also
you're going to end up being molid or
because if your oven is sitting at 250,
so the only way they're going to get
to 350 is probably, probably, or as if
your fire is going and you know it's
going and you hear the swish of the
gas and you open up and you see
that the fire is going up to 350
won't be a problem at all. But if
it's quiet and you look inside and you
don't see a fire going, so then you're
going to end up being molid or to
bring it up to 350, that's a problem.
Nu, so what does it so that's so
then what so that's why one has to
keep the fire on at the highest at
the temperature the higher temperature you want. That's
why you have to do the cheshbon. Now
what about the range? So the modern-day range
has an electric clicker. So when you turn
on your range the top of the range,
so the gas comes out and you hear
the clicker and the fire goes on. Okay,
so you're being molid or, it's a problem.
However, there are different kinds of ranges. Sometimes
the range has the clicker at the end
of the at the end of the dial.
So the gas come when you turn on
the gas, so you turn the gas on,
gas is coming out, you have to go
to high, when you go to high then
it clicks and then you have to adjust
it. So if that's the case then what
you could do is just turn on the
gas and bring an or from here from
Sometimes the clickers are not so, are not
so gevaldig, so you have to go very
slow if the clickers are at the beginning
of the dial. So you don't have this
other eitzah. But sometimes if you go very
quickly past the clicker, you won't end up
getting a spark and then you'll get the
gas and then you can transfer fire. But
if you have a shpitz range and it
works every single time, so then you're stuck
and you have to leave fire on for
Yom Tov. So now the new thing in
the market is the Shabbos mode. Just last
week somebody had a new fridge, a new
person in the community and they could not
and every time they opened the door the
light went on and the lights were hardwired.
And they didn't, and they were renting, so
they didn't buy a Shabbos mode fridge. So
they asked me what they should do, so
I came over and looked at it and
they said that they put a magnet, put
a magnet in certain place and you can
turn off. So they, I said use a
magnet. So I got this look like, you're
a Rabbi, not an alternative medicine guy, what
do you mean a magnet? I said, no,
no. So I happened to have a magnet
in the car from the thing which holds
the car to the phone. So I showed
him that if you put the magnet in
certain place, you can get the lights to
knock off. You have to get a magnet,
you have to, I don't know if there's
other stuff, I don't think you should keep
it there 24/7 because I don't know what
else is cutting off besides, but that's an
eitzah. So, but in this case you get
the Shabbos mode. So the Shabbos mode does
things that are very important and does things
that are questionable whether they're helpful. One thing
the Shabbos mode does, which is very, very
important, is that most ovens nowadays have a
12-hour cutoff. So if you leave your oven
on, so most states will not allow an
oven to be manufactured that doesn't have a
cutoff because they don't want a person leaving
their oven on and then going out and
forgetting about it. So the oven's cutoff is
12 hours, so that's a terrible thing for
a guy who wants to keep Yom Tov.
So you have to buy the Shabbos mode
because that bypasses, when you put on the
Shabbos mode, it bypasses the cutoff. Okay, that's
a good solution. And then the Shabbos mode
will knock off all the lights, so the
lights will not go on when you open
up the door to the oven, gevaldig, you
need that also. And then the Shabbos mode
will knock off all the digital readouts, which
might change when you open the door, also
very important. Okay, now the real issue that
has to be figured out is that Rabbi
Heinemann, who is not only a huge talmid
chacham and a very, very skilled technically, is
also a wonderful marketing person because he was
able to convince major brands to have a
Sabbath mode. Now the Sabbath mode doesn't do
anything for Shabbos, but you can't sell a
Yom Tov mode, so he sells a Shabbos
mode, sounds better. So that in America Shabbos
mode is sold. So it doesn't get in
the way of people Yom Tov mode. So
he sells a Sabbath, it does nothing for
Shabbos. It helps you because you can open
the door after the fire has gone off,
so it's helpful. So it's good. But for
Yom Tov, Rabbi Heinemann developed the Shabbos mode
so that whenever one raises the temperature, there's
a built-in delay and there's no digital readout.
So you know that you left your fire
on at 250, you now want to get
up to 360. How do you get up
to 360? You're going to end up putting
on a circuit, molid or. So what he
has is, first of all, you don't, there's
no digital readout. So you have to press
it once 260, twice 270, three times 280.
Okay, so you took care of the problem
of koseiv. How do you take care of
the problem of molid or and raising the
fire? So you put in a delay. So
by putting in the delay, it becomes a
grama of havarah and a grama of molid.
So that is highly questionable whether that in
fact is accurate. Rabbi Heinemann is again ashlei
ravrevei. Most poskim do not say that a
predictable delay makes it into a grama. Most
poskim say the difference between grama and a
maaseh is are you sure it's going to
happen. If you're sure it's going to happen,
then it's a maaseh. If you're not sure
it's going to happen, then it's grama. If
you open the door and you're sure that
the wind is going to blow up the
fire, that is a maaseh. If you open
the door and sometimes it doesn't, that's grama.
Right, if you put your bottles, your barrels
of water in front of the fire and
you're not sure whether the fire is going
to be doused because it'll break the barrels,
that's grama. So over here, a time delay
is highly questionable whether a time delay creates
a grama situation because you know it has
never failed. It may have taken two and
a half seconds, or it may have taken
five and a half seconds, but it's happened.
So that's highly questionable. There is a strong
source to say so, there is a Rashba
who seems to say that, it seems like
Rav Shlomo Zalman in some writings has accepted
the idea. But it's a very, very questionable
mahalach. I think most poskim, and I said
the Rav was very much against the idea.
In and he discussed Shabbos mode, he discussed
the idea of what's called grama. So that's
highly questionable if that is, if one can
rely on that nekudah for a Yom Tov.
You still need to get a Shabbos mode
oven because you need to have the cut-off
bypass. And you need the cut-off, the, you
need the Shabbos mode so you need to
get that you won't have digital readouts that
change when you open the door of the
oven, and that you don't have the lights
go on. The question is whether this extra
feature of the Shabbos mode, which Rabbi Heinemann
promoted as being allowed to change the flame
because it's only a grama and a grama
d'grama, so that's highly questionable whether you've accomplished
that or whether you're stuck with the way
it was before, that you have to leave
the oven on 360, whatever your wife decides,
whatever your mother decides to leave it on,
and work with it the way you work
with any other oven that you can't change
the, so that's again a Shulchan melacha and
it's a sugya that you have to work
through and take a position on because sometimes
you won't get asked, you'll have to teach
it, but the lashon is sometimes people assume
things. Good. So those I think are the
things which in my experience are very, very
prevalent issues that come up Yom Tov to
Yom Tov. You know, I'm sure it'll come
up in different ways as technology advances. Good.
So for me it was, I always enjoy
the opportunity to spend time with the guys
in semicha and at least have the recognition
and then of course if you're in semicha
and things come up and I can be
helpful, so happy to be helpful. Yeah. What's
the issue with raising the temperature on Yom
Tov? Well, because in modern day ovens it
will be molid or because it's an electric,
you're going to in most you're going to
shut down certain circuits and then some new
circuits. That's molid. Now not all, there are
some electric ovens which don't function that way.
And most gas, so most gas ovens you're
going to also, the way things work without
pilot lights, you're going to be molid a
new flame. Okay, we'll go make Mincha downstairs,
okay.